هناك لم تمضي اسابيع قليله على تعيينه
رئيسا للوزراء حتى وجد بني امينه ياهو
نفسه في مازق حقيقي وخروجا عن رغبته طره
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
لاقاله وزير الداخليه والصحه في حكومه
اريا درعي وذلك اذعانا لقرار المحكمه
العليا بابطال تعيينه بسبب ادانته في
قضايا فساد نتنياه لم يتخلى عن اهم حلفائه
حين تعهد بالسعي لاعاده درعيه الى الحكم
بالطرق القانونيه كما اتهم المحكمه
والمعارضه بالتشويش على عمله
اخراج درعا من منصبه سيضعف حكومه نتنياهو
لكونه الشريك الاقوى لنتنياهو في الحكومه
لكن اقاله درع ليست الا عقبه من بين عقبه
اخرى تواجهنا ياهو الذي وجد معارضه قويه
امامه فاصوات عديده تعالى في تظاهرات حاده
نظمت في عده مدن اسرائيليه تمديدا
بالاصلاحات التي دعا اليها وكان نحو مئه
الف اسرائيلي قد خرجوا الى شوارع تل ابيب
وكان معهم رئيس الوزراء السابق يائذ لبيد
لبيد زعيم المعارضه الحاليه شارك اذا
للمره الاولى في تظاهرات من هذا النوع
ونشر لابيد تغريده مرفقه بالصور تظهر
مشاركته في تظاهر تل ابيب قال انها تاتي
لمصلحه الدوله والدفاع عن الديمقراطيه كما
شهد تظاهرات مشاركه وزير الدفاع السابقس
نتنياهو وجد نفسه اذا في مواجهه تظاهرات
وصفت بالاكبر في اسرائيل منذ نحو عقدا من
الزمن
وتتواصل الحركه الاحتجاجيه ضد حكومه
نتنياهو حيث ارتفعت دعوات دعوات من
المعارضه الى تصعيدها باضرابات لشل اقتصاد
البلاد هذا وتواصلت لانتقادات لموجهه
للاصلاحات التي اقترحها نتنياهو حيث وصفت
رئيسه المحكمه الدستوريه العليا
التشريعات المقترحه بانها هجوم جامح على
الجهاز القضائي في البلاد مصائب نتنياهو
لم تتوقف عند هذا الحد حيث يواجه ايضا
انتقادات من وزراء الصهيونيه الدينيه
احتجاجا على اخلاق بؤره الاستيطانيه في
الضفه الغربيه في ازمه اخرى تهدد حكومه
نتانيا